WE COULD GO ON, BUT IT'S
DISGUSTING.
HE GOES TO PRISON FOR NINE
MONTHS.
IT'S A GOOD THING HE DIDN'T
QUESTION DIVERSELY BECAUSE THEN
HE'D BE IN REAL TROUBLE.
WE HAVE TOLD YOU ON THE SHOW A
COUPLE OF TIMES ABOUT DECLINING
STANDARDS AT THE FAA, PLIGHT OF
PART OF THE WIDER WAR ON
STANDARDS.
IN THE NAME OF DIVERSITY, THE
FAA HAS ADDED AN IRRELEVANT
BIOGRAPHICAL SECTION TO ITS
HIRING PROCESS FOR AIR-TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS.
CONGRESS COULD INTERVENE AND
DICTATE THAT HIRING BE SOLELY
BASED ON QUALIFICATIONS.
WE HOPE THAT HAPPENS AND SO DOES
CHAIRMAN FRANK KOLBE ANDO.
SO AS YOU ALREADY KNOW, THE FAA
INTENTIONALLY SEEKS OUT
UNQUALIFIED AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS WHICH IS WHOLE
HORRIFYING.
WHAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT IS WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS?
>> FIRST, THANK YOU FOR RAISING
THIS AGAIN.
IT WAS YOUR NETWORK WHO FIRST
RAISED IT A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
AND GAVE US THE ABILITY TO GET
SOME TRACTION, BUT UNFORTUNATELY
UNFORTUNATELY IT GOT SHOT IN THE
DOOR.
WE WERE BLINDSIDED.
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND THE FAA ADMINISTRATOR AT THE
TIME, MICHAEL WIRT, NORMALLY
THEY COME TO CONGRESS AND SAY,
WE ARE GOING TO CHANGE THE
PROCEDURES.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE,
AIR-TRAFFIC CONTROLLER
QUALIFYING.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
NOTHING, JUST DID IT AND
BLINDSIDED US.
WE STARTED ASKING QUESTIONS, WHY
DID YOU DO IT?
DID YOU CHECK THIS BIOGRAPHICAL
APP TO MAKE SURE IT WAS GOING TO
WORK?
NOTHING, SILENCE.
WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING THIS FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS, WITHOUT GETTING
ANY ANSWERS AND ANY EXPLANATION
AS TO WHY COME UP WITH A TOTAL
BLINDSIDE.
WE HAD THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVOLVED.
WE HAVE THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTING OFFICE INVOLVED, AND
IT YOU HAD A VERY ABLE GUEST ON,
MICHAEL PEARSON, WHO HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE LAWSUIT, BOTH
OF THESE AGENCIES SHUT DOWN.
SO WHAT WAS THE MOST EGREGIOUS
PART OF THIS?
WE HAVE ALREADY ATTEMPTED AND
ADDRESSED, AND THAT IS THE CTI
STUDENTS.
THAT'S HOW IT FIRST CAME TO ME.
>> Tucker: THEY INTENTIONALLY
GO TO SCHOOL TO BE AIR-TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS.
>> THEY HAVE THE APTITUDE AND
PAY TENS OF THOUSANDS TO DO
THIS.
IT'S AMAZING, AND THEY HAVE THE
RUG PULLED OUT FROM UNDER THEM.
THEY WERE TOTALLY QUALIFIED AND
TOLD HER, SORRY.
>> SO IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT
SHOULD THAT DEFENDS IT?
>> I DOUBT IT.
>> Tucker: SO WHY SHOULDN'T
CONGRESS PASSED IN ITS
AUTHORIZATION FOR FUNDING FOR
THE FAA A RULE THAT SAYS YOU
CANNOT USE IRRELEVANT CRITERIA
FOR HIRING AIR-TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS?
IT'S TOO IMPORTANT.
COULD WE DO THAT?
>> IF I WERE WRITING A BILL AND
WERE ABLE TO DO IT WITHOUT THE
CONSENT OF OUR SENATE AND ABLE
TO DO IT THROUGH OUR COMMITTEE,
I WOULD DO IT.
>> Tucker: NEED TO HIRE
UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE WHO ARE BAD AT
SCIENCE.
>> THEY WON'T PUT IT THAT WAY,
BUT YOU KNOW THE WAY IT WORKS.
IT HAS TO GO TO CONFERENCE AND
THE SENATE GETS INVOLVED AND IT
GETS MOCKED UP.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THEY
UNDERSTAND -- THESE ARE
AIR-TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS.
>> PEOPLE AREN'T PAYING
ATTENTION TO IT.
BUT WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO POINT
OUT IS THAT THE CTI STUDENTS,
AND MAY BE MOST EGREGIOUSLY,
MILITARY, A FORMER MILITARY,
ESPECIALLY MILITARY AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS ARE NOW INTO THE MIX
AGAIN.
>> Tucker: IT'S GOOD TO COME
UP BUT IF THERE IS A SINGLE
PERSON WHO IS UNQUALIFIED AND
HIRED FOR THIS JOB AGAIN, THIS
IS NOT TO BECOME A GYM TEACHER.
THESE ARE AIR-TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS.
>> AND THIS IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
KNOW.
IF ONE OF THESE PEOPLE WHO MAYBE
DOESN'T BELONG THERE GETS
THROUGH THE INITIAL PROCESS,
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
ACADEMY, AND THEY ARE WASHED OUT
BECAUSE THE ACADEMY PUTS UP WITH
NO NONSENSE.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE MORE
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR
BUREAUCRACY.
AND YOU ARE GRADED ON IRRELEVANT
CRITERIA, AND SO, IT'S WRONG.